المترجم: Rouaa Ez Edeen
المدقّق: Nada Qanbar
مرحبًا.
أنا اسمي مايا باتساليدس.
قصتي تتعلق بتحدي شخصي،
تتعلق بقصّة خاصّة جدًا. قصة تخصني.
أولًا، دعوني أخبركم
لماذا أتحدث بهذا الشكل.
سأبدأ بعام 2001،
كنت عائدة حديثًا من مصر، ومن بريطانيا
عائدة إلى الشّام،
إنّني بطبعي شخص دائم الحركة،
شخص مليء بالحياة،
شخص نشيط، يتحرك هنا وهناك،
كنت ضمن الكورال، الكشّاف،
أمارس ركوب الخيل، السباحة، عزف البيانو،
لا أستطيع البقاء بلا حراك.
كنت عائدة من سفري، وكنت قد بدأت بالعمل،
بدأت بالعمل مع شركات كبيرة
بمجال الدعاية والتسويق.
ثم أسست شركة خاصة بي،
هي دايركت لاين (Direct line)،
شركة إعلانات ووكالة إنتاج.
بدأت بمشروع صغير،
أول عمل بدأته مع مجموعة قنوات MBC.
وفقني الله، وبدأت أنطلق في
مسيرتي المهنية، وتابعت عملي.
كنت في بداية انطلاقتي، في بداية شبابي.
في عام 2004، تزوّجت
وسرعان ما أصبحت حاملًا.
وخلال فترة الحمل،
حدث معي أمر غريب قليلًا،
غريب كثيرًا إذا أردتم الحقيقة.
شعرت بالتعب خلال فترة حملي،
لم أستطع فهم ما يحدث لي،
لم يتم تشخيص حالتي،
بدأ التعب يتمالكني،
شعرت بوهنٍ في قدمي،
وبوهنٍ في يدي،
أصبح كلامي غير مفهومٍ،
وضعُف نظري،
ولم يتم تشخيص المرض.
ذهبت إلى عدّة وجهات،
قابلت العديد من الأطباء،
ولم يتم تشخيص مرضي.
حتّى أنّهم في البداية،
شكّوا بأنّي أتظاهر بالمرض (دلال الحوامل).
بأنّني عروس حديثة العهد، وحامل
وأريد الحصول على الاهتمام منهم.
لم تلبث صحّتي أن تعافت قليلًا،
حتّى سارعت بالعودة إلى عملي.
كنت أتابع عملي، أتابع حلمي
ومتابعةً مسيرتي المهنية وطريقي.
عادت حالتي لتسوء،
ساءت لحدود كما قلت لكم، لم تعد مفهومة.
بدأ الرجفان والوهن يصيب قدمي اليمنى،
ثم يدي اليمنى، ثم قدمي اليسرى،
ثم يدي اليسرى
الكلام، البلع، والرؤية
كلها تضرّرت.
الكثير من الأطباء قالوا لي،
والكثير من الأصدقاء قالوا لي،
أجهضي هذا الطفل، تخلصي منه
لتتمكني من معالجة مرضك.
جوابي كان قاطعًا،
أنا لن أجهض الطفل.
الطفل هو هدية من السماء،
هو نعمة من الله،
ليس لديّ الحق بإجهاضه.
وهذا ما قمت به.
وتابعت ذلك إلى الوقت الذي
ساءت فيه حالتي بشكل كبير جدًا.
ذهبت إلى الجامعة الأمريكية ببيروت لأضع.
ولدت ابنتي، لكنني لم أُرِد
رؤيتها في اليوم الأول.
كنت عمليًا، لا أرى،
لا أستطيع المشي والتحرك.
لذلك، لم أستطع رؤيتها في اليوم الأول.
رأيت ابنتي في اليوم الثاني،
عندما رأيتها أحسست أنني
ملكت الدنيا بأكملها.
أحسست بأنني لا أريد شيئًا من هذه الدنيا.
وسرعان ما تولّدت بداخلي طاقة،
وتولّدت بداخلي قوة، لا أستطيع تفسيرها.
لا أستطيع شرحها لأيّ أحد.
بعد أن ولدت ابنتي،
لم يعد لديّ بداخلي ما أخاف عليه.
إذا وقعتُ، أو تعثّرتُ، لا مشكلة
فلم يعد لديّ ما أخاف عليه.
وهذا ما فعلته،
في يوم ولادتي، كنت أحتاج لثلاثة
أشخاص لنقلي من مكان للآخر.
وطلب المعالج الفيزيائي أن أمشي،
أن أمشي أمتار قليلة،
ونهضت ومشيت،
على الرغم من عدم قدرتي على ذلك.
استغرق مني ثلث الساعة، لأمشي عدّة أمتار.
لكنني مشيتها.
عندما عدت إلى الشّام،
لأكمل معالجتي الفيزيائية.
أردت أن أنهض، أن أكمل حياتي من جديد.
سأخبركم قصّة سخيفة، مضحكة جدًا.
ذهبت إلى المعالج الفيزيائي،
طلب مني المشي على جهاز المشي.
فقام بتشغيله، وذهب.
عندما قام بذلك، ملأت الحيّ
بأكمله ببكائي وصراخي،
سمع صراخي وبكائي جميع أهالي الحيّ.
ثم عاد إليّ واعتذر، بقوله: "عفوًا".
قام بإطفائها، وجلست جانبًا أبكي.
مرّت ساعة وأنا أبكي.
وعندما فرغ المركز من زائريه
لملمت تعبي ولملمت ضعفي كلّه،
وصعدت على آلة المشي، ومشيت.
كان المعالج قد طلب مني أن أمشي لدقيقة،
عندها مشيت ثلث ساعة.
هذه القوة الداخلية، هذه الطاقة الداخلية
التي لم أجد تفسيرًا لها.
هذا الحافز الداخلي، كان بداخلي سلام
لا أستطيع تفسيره.
لكن أستطيع القول،
أنّه كان لدي مجموعة حوافز خاصة بي.
أنا لا أستطيع أن أكون مريضةً،
لا أرضى أن أكون مريضةً.
لا أستطيع أن أجلس بلا حراك.
أنا أم،
وأريد أن أكون أم صالحة.
أريد أن أرعى ابنتي، أن أكون قدوةً لها،
أن أكون أمًا تفتخر بها،
لا أن أكون أمًا تخجل منها.
في نفس الوقت، أهلي، أمي وأبي
وإخوتي، وأصدقائي
كانوا يحيطونني بمحبة ودعم لا يوصف.
عندما تكون محاطًا بمحبة، هناك ما يحفّزك.
الشيء الرابع هو مستقبلي،
أنا لم أتعب، وأجتهد بدراستي طوال عمري،
حتى أجلس بلا عمل.
أن أمرض وأجلس في الفراش،
وانتهى الأمر.
لا أرضى ولا أسمح أن يحصل ذلك.
الشيء الخامس، أنا أحب
السيدة مريم العذراء،
أنا أحب الله كثيرًا، وأعرف أنه يحبنا.
يحبنا جميعًا،
وأيّ شيء نطلبه منه وفيه خير لنا،
فيه مصلحتنا، يعطيه لنا.
بدأت صحتي بالتّحسن،
في كلّ شيء ذكرته، لم أتوقف عن العمل.
كنت أعمل من منزلي،
عندما بدأت صحتي تتحسن،
عدت إلى العمل، عدت إلى شركتي،
أعتذر في الاجتماع على طريقتي في الكلام،
ولكنني هكذا أتحدث، ومن ثم أعود للعمل.
في إحدى المرات، اتصل بي أحد أصدقائي،
قال لي: "يوجد مركز تعليم لغات يريدون أن
يقوم أحدهم بِعَمل أفلام لجامعة تكساس."
عندها، كان شكلي غير لائق،
كنت آخذ إبرًا في عيني،
والكُحْل يصل إلى هنا، إلى منتصف خدّي،
وكما قلت لكم،
لا يوجد أي شيء (في جسدي) يعمل جيدًا.
كنت لا أكتب، وبالكاد أرى، ولا أتكلم جيدًا،
لا أبلع ولا أتنفس بشكل صحيح،
لا يوجد شيء صحيح.
قلت له: وماذا أعجبهم فيّ أنا،
لماذا اختاروني كمخرجة،
قلت له: لا أستطيع أن أقدّم نفسي كمخرجة،
بعدها، جلست مع نفسي،
وقلت لماذا لا أستطيع،
أنا أستطيع أن أقوم بذلك.
ذهبتُ،
واعتذرتُ من شكلي غير اللائق،
وحضّرت العرض وقدّمته.
وأخذت الفرصة، وقمت بالعمل.
بالنسبة لي، رأى الناس شخصي من الداخل،
لم يروا شكلي الخارجي.
لم يروا ذلك الشبه إنسان
المتقدّم إلى فرصة العمل،
بل رأوني من الداخل،
تعرّفوا عليّ من الداخل.
تقّدمت إلى العمل وأخذت الفرصة،
جامعة تكساس شجّعت جامعة يال،
ثم شجّعت جامعة جورج واشنطن.
أخذت جائزة، وأخذت رسالة شكر
من جامعة يال،
أخذت شركتي "دايركت لاين" رسالة شكر
من الميثاق العالمي للأمم المتحدة،
كأفضل شركة في مجال البيع في سوريا.
حاليًا، أقوم بسرد الأحداث
التي حصلت معي سريعًا،
هذه القصّة حدثت معي منذ سنين،
بالمناسبة، أنا أنجبت طفلة ثانية،
لا تسألوني كيف حدث ذلك،
لكنّني أنجبت طفلة ثانية،
(ضحك)
لماذا لم أخف؟ كيف حصل ذلك؟
أصبح لدي طفلتان، هنّ فرحة قلبي،
وهدفي في الحياة، بغض النظر
عن حلمي ومستقبلي وعملي،
هم أطفالي، هم المستقبل،
أتمنى أن أزرع بداخلهم ما بداخلي،
أن يفهموا تجربتي، ويستفيدوا منها.
أن يحبوا، أن يتعلموا العطاء.
هنّ كل فرحتي في هذه الدنيا.
ترونني واقفة أمامكم، أحادثكم،
ولكنني لم أسترد صحتي كاملةً.
لا زلت أحتاج مساعدة في صعود الدرج،
لا أستطيع الكتابة بالقلم،
ولا أستطيع الطباعة على الحاسوب،
لا أستطيع الركض، وآكل بصعوبة.
أسلوب حياتي صعب،
وحتى لو أنها كذلك لكنّها لا تتوقف.
ولا يجب أن تقف،
والحياة صعبة، أتعب وأعمل،
لكنني لا أتوقّف.
(تصفيق)
رسالتي صغيرة لكم في TEDx،
وأكرر لكم ما قلته،
لا يوجد في الحياة ما هو مستحيل.
يوجد صعوبات وعقبات ومشاكل،
لكنها ليست مستحيلة.
يجب أن نكافح قليلًا، أن نجاهد قليلًا،
أن نحارب قليلًا،
- المعنى الإيجابي للمحاربة -
(ضحك)
نحارب لنصل لما نريده،
لا يوجد مستحيل.
قصتي، هي إحدى قصص الكثير من الناس،
الذين عانوا بشكل أكثر أو أقل،
أحبّ أن يتذكر كل من سمع بقصتي،
أنه لا يوجد شيء مستحيل.
أحيطوا أنفسكم بأشخاص تحبونهم ويحبونكم،
استمروا بالعطاء، ثقوا بالله، ثقوا بأنفسكم.
وفي النهاية، ما فيه خير لكم ستقومون به،
حياتكم لا تكون،
إلاّ كما تريدون لها أن تكون.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق)